how's it going bros my name is pierre i
have so much to talk about so we're just
gonna do that i don't know if you
noticed but I've been away for a week I
got to go to LA to have a showdown
versus mr. CaptainSparklez where we
played disney infinity 3.0 multiplayer
it's gonna be up on the channel I'm not
gonna spoil anything
but I guess spray again I don't know why
I whispered I'm pretty sure we're not
friends anymore
you said you make me sparkles I'm just
kidding of course we're friends but I
had it so much fun it's gonna be a great
video I'm excited to share with you bros
just infinity 3.0 it looks super cool
and I'm super excited to share the video
with you bros it's gonna be a lot of fun
I also did some other stuff while I was
in LA but I can't talk about it
so I don't know why I'm telling you my
point is there's so much going on right
now and it's it's super late even while
I'm recording this because I just have
so much to do but it's so much fun to
cuz there's so many cool things that I
can share with you bros and we announced
yesterday for example that I wrote a
book called this book loves you finally
something loves you I'm kidding I'm
kidding I love you don't cry it's really
been amazing feedback from you bros so
far like you you seem so excited for it
and some of am I so I used to make these
silly tweets that were just like really
horrible life advice and you bros would
take them and put them in a really cute
and funny way so I thought that would
make a really funny book I can't wait to
share it with your brothers it's been so
much fun working on it you can check out
all the info I leave in the description
you can pre-order it if you want it's
available in a lot of different
countries already and it's all due to
popular demand so if it's not in your
country it's it's not in my control I'm
sorry
hopefully if enough people give it
enough attention it will be available
but it should be for everyone online
another reason I'm so excited for this
book to finally come out is because I'm
gonna do book tours we haven't announced
the date or location yet but I am just
so excited to meet you bros face to face
I don't want to sound like I don't know
but I do get recognized a lot on the
street like it happens I'd say almost
every day and it's it's always a fun and
positive experience that I really love
but there's always the hey I know I'm
gonna sound stupid there's no worry
there's always a feeling in the back of
my head like are they excited to see me
because say they watch my videos and
they enjoy what I do
or are they excited to see me because
they think I'm famous I I can't shake
that idea from my head and that's I
don't like that and that's why I don't
like going to events as well cuz it
really feels like I'm just going there
to just yeah I'm here just give it all
to me all the attention tell me how good
I am when honestly I just want to meet
you brother
that's what I'm excited about so for
this book tour if it gives me a chance
to meet the Bros that support me and
what I do cuz you you are the ones I
want to meet and you really really do
mean so much to me so I'm just so
excited to meet your brothers in person
it's gonna be great I'm super excited I
know I said it many times that's all for
now
gross it's just so incredible how I can
go to I get to fly to LA to play disney
infinity 3.0 before the game is even out
and I
to do all these other cool things just
thanks to YouTube and that really boils
down to thanks to you Bruce and I really
truly am thankful for it so as always
we're gonna end with the brofist
alright breasts stay awesome